Imaginemos que cada uno de estos pequeños círculos
de aquí representa un miembro de una población de
insectos, y tenemos dos poblaciones diferentes
de insectos: tenemos a la población 1 del lado
izquierdo de esta línea naranja y a la población
2 del lado derecho. Y vamos a pensar en un sólo
rasgo de estos insectos: su color, porque es fácil
de visualizar. Y digamos que su color les ayuda
a camuflarse de los depredadores, así que tal
vez esta capa, que es un tipo de nube blanca,
negra y verde, sea el ambiente en el que
habitan, donde podemos encontrarlos, tal vez
sea la superficie del musgo que cubre un árbol o
algo así. Y estas dos son poblaciones separadas,
tal vez sean especies relacionadas o tal vez sean
la misma, pero tenemos dos poblaciones distintas
que no se entremezclan. Ahora, la primera pregunta
es ¿cuál de estas dos poblaciones tiene una mayor
diversidad genética? Bueno, a la izquierda
podemos ver que todos tienen el mismo color,
parece que es un color bastante útil para poder
esconderse, los camufla bastante bien; mientras
que a la derecha es claro que hay más variedad de
colores, algunos de ellos tienen un color similar
a los que vemos en el lado izquierdo, pero algunos
de ellos son más oscuros y otros son más claros.
Así que la población de la derecha tiene más
diversidad. Ahora bien, se podría argumentar
que algunos de estos círculos más brillantes
o algunos de estos más oscuros pueden ser más
susceptibles a los depredadores; y de hecho este
puede ser el caso Pero en este video no vamos a
pensar en cuántos miembros de la población son
más o menos susceptibles a los depredadores,
en cambio lo que quiero que pensemos es si la
diversidad ayuda cuando puede haber algún tipo
de cambio en el ambiente ¿será que esto hace que
la población en conjunto sea más resiliente? Y,
ojo, no estamos hablando de manera individual de
un miembro de la población. Para imaginar esto
pensemos que surge algún tipo de cambio en el
ambiente, tal vez haya contaminación en el área
que haga que se oscurezca un poco la superficie
donde tienen que vivir estos insectos, así que
tal vez la superficie se vea así. Entonces,
¿qué es probable que suceda ahora? Bueno,
en esta realidad todos los insectos del lado
izquierdo son más visibles a los depredadores,
podemos imaginar que los depredadores podrán
comerse a muchos más de ellos o en un caso extremo
tal vez sean capaces de terminar con todos ellos;
mientras que en la derecha los depredadores serán
capaces de alimentarse de algunos de los miembros
de la población como este y este y este y este,
mientras que otros miembros de la población
se camuflan mejor que antes, como este y este
y este. Entonces, debido a la diversidad de
la población, aunque muchos miembros podrían
morir o ser eliminados por los depredadores,
parece que hay un subconjunto de la población
que tendrá más probabilidades de sobrevivir
y que podrá continuar reproduciéndose y,
por lo tanto, no morirá toda la población.
Y podrías pensarlo al revés: imagina que en
lugar de que el ambiente sea más oscuro, imagina
que el ambiente se vuelve más claro, algo así.
Bueno, puedes ver un fenómeno similar. Ahora
todos los individuos del lado izquierdo son
mucho más visibles, y tal vez los depredadores se
los coman; mientras que a la derecha sólo algunos
de los individuos son más visibles, en este caso
los oscuros son súper visibles y los depredadores
podrán distinguirlos mejor y comérselos, incluso
también de algunos de color intermedio. Sin
embargo, también hay un gran número de ellos que
hasta ahora se mimetizan bien, como este y este,
están tan bien camuflados que ni siquiera puedo
verlos, y este. Así que una vez más, hay ciertos
miembros de la población que, dada esta mayor
diversidad, tienen mayor probabilidad de poder
sobrevivir a algún tipo de alteración ambiental,
y como es más probable que algunos sobrevivan,
es menos probable que toda la población muera.
Por lo tanto, la población en su conjunto tiene
mayor resiliencia. No estoy diciendo que cada
miembro de la población sea más resiliente,
pero sí la población como un todo. Así que el
escenario general es que mayor diversidad conduce
a mayor resiliencia ambiental o resiliencia
a los cambios en el ambiente. Una vez más:
no estamos diciendo que cada miembro individual de
la población sea más resiliente, estamos diciendo
que la población en su conjunto es más capaz de
sobrevivir en cierto sentido y seguir adelante.